>>> Elon Musk rather subtle in slamming advertisers
for abandoning X after he endorsed an anti-semitic
post on the platform.
>> If somebody's going to try to blackmail
me with advertising, blackmail me with money,
go
[ bleep ] Yourself.
But go [ bleep ] Yourself.
Is that clear?
I hope it is.
>> Kind of seems like he wanted more of a
reaction so he tried it again with the audience
there.
It all happened last night during that live
audience interview with Andrew Ross Sorkin
at "The New York Times" deal summit.
Musk did apologize for endorsing anti-semitic
post calling it the worst and dumbest social
media post he's ever done.
Joining us now CNN contributor Kara swisher.
Good to have you with us this morning.
I guess he got the chuckle on the second he
was looking for in that statement.
>> I guess.
>> It's fascinating to me,
[7:46:15 AM]
>> It's fascinating to me, though, as we watch
this, right, and he's there on the stage,
and he seems to really be enjoying the moment,
we have this estimate that from "The New York
Times", I believe, that he's going to lose
$75 million in revenue.
And he's sort of saying, fine, we don't need
you.
But the business itself needs them, and they're
going away because of what he did.
>> Yes, yes, he's -- let me just underscore
for the audience, he's 52 years old.
This is a 52-year-old man who feels the need
to say dirty words to make people shocked.
It's just -- it's bizarre and he caused the
problem, and he wants to blame them for exercising
their first amendment right not to advertise
on his terrible platform, I think.
It's really bizarre.
It was a bizarre performance.
It was a meltdown.
He seemed -- he attacked Bob iger who was
in the audience, the head of Disney for just
not wanting to advertise on him.
It was so strange, and he's done it before.
He's attacked advertisers when he first bought
the company because he was frustrated, but
again, let me underscore, he's
[7:47:15 AM]
again, let me underscore, he's 52 years old
and the richest person in the world, and I'm
sorry he's -- that's not how adults behave.
It's how adult toddlers behave.
>> And also, certainly not how public company
-- heads of public companies behave.
One of the drivers of how that public company
is S supposed to survive is the advertising,
the person responsible for the advertising
came over with much fanfare, Linda Yaccarino.
I'm struck, she put out a tweet last night,
I don't know what it was trying to do to be
completely candid with you, saying here's
my perspective when it comes to advertising.
>> Neither do I.
>> X is standing at a unique and main intersection
and the X community is power and feel here
to welcome you.
To our partners who believe in our meaningful
work, thank you.
It's like a tweeting through it but not really
sure with what capacity.
>> She's -- did you watch succession?
>> Yeah.
>> The pain sponge, that's what she is.
She's the pain sponge for this behavior.
[7:48:15 AM]
behavior.
This is an experienced ad exec.
She knows exactly what happened here.
For some reason she's decided to enable him.
That's the real problem here.
Besides his ridiculous behavior and childish
behavior, she's also enabling him and making
excuses and trying to wrap it in the cloak
of the first amendment.
In fact, you don't have to advertise where
you don't want to.
I think that's pretty much the basics of advertising.
People pick and choose, and they've picked,
and instead he wants to blame them for his
own behavior.
It was such a bizarre -- it's not bizarre,
he's done it before.
He just keeps doing it and keeps doubling
down, and so, you know, at one point, you
know, as Maya Angelou says when someone tells
you who they are, believe them.
>> In the grand scheme of things sort of on
brand.
I was also struck by Israel's president was
also interviewed at deal book, and he was
asked specifically about the visit that Elon
Musk made.
He was also asked -- he said he appreciated
it, but he was asked whether he thought Elon
Musk would actually be fighting anti-semitism
on X, and he didn't really give an answer,
which to me told us everything
[7:49:16 AM]
which to me told us everything we needed to
know.
>> How could he.
Right, how could he.
It's become, you know, he's allowed all kinds
of -- he got rid of content moderation.
He said everyone should be able to say whatever.
That trip was a pr stunt, and it was -- a
lot of people in Israel thought it was shameful
for the government to do that, but they need
help too I guess, you know.
What's happening there, especially Netanyahu.
Netanyahu has come to his aid before when
he had another issue around anti-semitism
with the adl, and so this just happens over
and over again.
And what's fascinating is the blame he wants
-- the richest man in the world wants to say
advertisers are the cause of his problems.
He's the cause of his problems, and the reason
ads are down is because of how he behaves
on the platform, not just promoting anti-semitic
stuff or allowing it to run rampant, study
afterdy shows this.
But he sues people or he cuts them off or
he calls them name, Bob iger, it's his fault
he is losing all
[7:50:17 AM]
it's his fault he is losing all this money
and he is going to have to pay the price.
He said that on stage.
It's not a public company.
It's his company.
Can afford to keep doing this.
>> We got to go.
Great point.
Keying on the iger comment, which I don't
think has gotten as much attention as it should.
It was a one-off, what the heck?